il pèse lourd très lourd dans la balance
150 emplois menacés à l'échelle d'une
ville de 20000 habitants comme
Romorantin leur suppression serait un
désastre social l'entreprise Colonna
facility en grande difficulté n'a plus
que quelques jours pour sauver ce qui
représente la moitié de ses effectifs
les détails avec les autres
depuis un an Colonna tente de calmer la
tempête en interne la résiliation d'un
contrat menace la moitié des effectifs
locaux une décision unilatérale prise
par les fournisseurs klesia et Malakoff
Humanis direction et collective de
salariés sont dans l'incompréhension
d'autant plus qu'aucun soutien n'a été
trouvé auprès de plusieurs syndicats
nationaux aujourd'hui les organisations
syndicales sont absentes elles ne
prennent pas la main elles ne prennent
pas position elle ne répond pas non plus
aux interrogations qu'on peut poser le
collectif de salariés dont je fais
partie sur cette résiliation
complètement incompréhensible mais celle
qui nous appuie et qui effectivement
veulent reprendre la main aujourd'hui
c'est les organisations patronales prix
compétitif retour client positif la fin
de ce contrat est injustifié aux yeux de
l'entreprise Colonna souhaiterait être
consulté afin de défendre sa position en
jouant la carte de dynamisme local
certifié France Garantie avec des
bureaux installés à deux pas du
centre-ville Colonna Eric tout un bassin
d'emploi la perte de collaborateurs ne
seraient pas sans conséquence sur
l'attractivité du territoire nous sommes
proches des écoles proches des commerces
des commerces des restaurants ce sont
ouverts grâce à notre implantation
depuis plus de 15 ans et au niveau
restaurateur je pense qu'il risque d'y
avoir des fermetures ce qui est
paradoxal puisque c'est nos clients les
hôtels cafés restaurants et puis ça
mettra en difficulté des commerces et
puis ça pourrait faire déménager des
familles et donc avoir aussi une
influence sur l'immobilier et le Loco
est mère de Romorantin son mobilisés aux
côtés de l'entreprise et ce sont
rapprochés des services de l'État les
salariés espèrent voir les choses bouger
d'ici les prochaines négociations début
juillet le contrat sera officiellement
résilié le 31 décembre 2023